Prime Minister.
Thank you so much for being here with us on
DW News.
You've taken over Sudan at a historical moment.
The country has is facing many challenges,
did you have any doubts about wanting to take
this role?
It's not really a personal wish.
This is a wish that is responding to a call
of duty.
So I did not have a single doubt in responding
to that, knowing so well, it is full of challenges,
it is dynamic, it is non-linear.
You get it right today.
You have problems and hurdles tomorrow.
Taking this job was a response to the calls
of the nation, my people who have managed
to give the world one of the probably very
rare moments of change particularly in our
history something that we equate it to the
great moments in nations’ history, equal
to the fall of the Berlin Wall, years or centuries
back probably, the French Revolution.
That momentous change created the environment
for me and many others to come, to help build
a news nation, it is a dawn.
I was in Sudan back in April at the sit-in
front of the military headquarters and I saw
many young people.
They were full of expectation and hope from
the government that eventually became your
government.
Do you feel like your government is living
up to their expectations?
This is what make(s) us tick, the hope, the
expectations about us, about the change (from)
the government by our people.
We never promised that we are willing to do
this on our own.
It's a shared responsibility, we rise and
fall in this process together with one conviction
that we have two options either to succeed
or succeed.
And I think we are moving in that direction.
But a lot of young people that I've spoken
to in the past couple of days say the things
that they went to the streets for, like basic
living conditions including bread.
These things have not been fulfilled.
So do you think that the young people's expectations
were too high?
no their expectations were never too high.
It is normal expectations by any government
by its people.
But also I'm sure they understand, they appreciate,
we inherited a daunting challenge a legacy
of 30 years.
You cannot undo it overnight but I think equipped
with that conviction and determination with
our people working together.
We had no doubts that we will be able to address
this and overcome these challenges.
What do you tell the young people who perhaps
are feeling impatient with the delivery of
actual results to their lives?
One thing let us work together to address
these issues.
Expectations are one thing, but let us address
these expectations together.
Our interests are aligned we don't have different
interests from theirs, expectation is the
same.
So let us join forces in addressing all this
challenges together.
Sudan is being run now under a unique cooperation
between civilians and military.
How is the cooperation between these two sides?
Because it hasn't always been smooth has it?
Yes.
This is also another feature of the uniqueness
of this Sudanese experiment.
We are proudly propagating this across the
world and calling it the Sudanese model which
is a partnership between the civilian and
the military, to build democracy with the
solid foundation for democracy.
This partnership is working.
It is not free from challenges, there are
so many challenges.
But I think there is a determination on both
sides to make it work and we are doing that
precisely.
If you look at the region around us the failures
in many places, because I think they were
not able to establish an accord that would
allow such partnership to move the country
forward.
We know we are experimenting with it.
We know there is no transition that is smooth,
transitions are always messy non-linear and
I think that in itself what makes it a very
interesting experiment to be a part of.
Do you trust the military side of your government?
Do you trust them?
Absolutely, I do
Because some young people that I've spoken
to have said this military has been involved
in the oppression and at some point even the
killing of so many protesters.
I do appreciate the views that expressed by
our young people.
Remember these are young people who are subjected
to all kinds of oppression.
You lived through that and you know it in
the streets and all this for years for decades.
That's why they have these views.
But I think gradually we are building this
partnership together.
None of this equation, these two sides of
the equation will be able to move on their
own to build this new nation.
I appreciate those views but we are working
together to address them.
Let's turn to the topic of the clearing of
the sit in in June and the people that were
killed on the streets.
A lot of them believe that the Rapid Support
Forces were involved in this attack.
When will these people see justice?
Because so far some say the results just have
not been up to what happened to protesters
on the streets.
I'm sure you know so well.
The Constitutional document which is guiding
this transitional period has a very clear
undertaking that we establish an investigation
committee.
So let us not jump to conclusion, that investigation
committee formed from very respected lawyers
and people in the legal field in Sudan.
They started their work over three months
now and they are doing their work and produce
the report.
You recently requested that U.N. peacekeeping
forces be deployed and the whole of Sudan.
Why did you do that?
Why is the U.N. needed now in Sudan?
Actually let us put this into its proper context.
We did not just wake up one day and said we
want the U.N. to come to the country.
The U.N. is there, we are not calling it
but for the whole of Sudan?
The U.N. is there under Chapter 7 meaning
that if there is anything that you could closely
call it loss of sovereignty, is what is happening
today.
What we are calling for is to move the U.N.
from Chapter 7 to Chapter 6 which would allow
us to express our wish and if you could call
it anywhere, dictate on the UN on our priorities.
This is where we would like to create an opportunity
where we tell the U.N., this is what we want
like you to come do one, two, three, four,
on our terms.
The whole country approach is an idea we discussed
in our national committee for a number of
months.
What it tells us, in the past that the U.N.
intervention in Sudan was compartmentalized;
it is in Darfur, in Blue Nile, in the Nuba
Mountains, South Kordofan and all that.
What would like to see, when we see as a whole
country approach is addressing the challenges
and the issues and the requirement and objectives
of the entire transitional period.
This certainly has some agenda which is of
national nature of a whole country.
When you talk about elections, we will not
just have them in Darfur; it will be the whole
country.
A constitutional conference it will engulf
the entire country, the process itself.
We would like to enlist the support of the
U.N. in those processes of a national nature
that is why we call it a whole country approach.
The support could be providing one adviser
could be providing technical support.
Take an example, the election.
Today we would like to embark on a process
that will conclude this transitional period
with an election.
The U.N. has accumulated experiences technical
and otherwise across the globe, support on
addressing issues of election systems an election
system that will provide us with an opportunity
to represent all our people.
The U.N could provide that so it's not about
entrusting this entirely to the U.N.
The funding of the elections, the U.N. has
accumulated very rich experience in generating
resources and funds to support the elections.
So it is only perfect and we are part of the
U.N., it’s not like another body will rule
somebody but it's coming from somewhere.
let's turn to the topic of the hour the possibility
of former President Ahmed Bashir to appear
before the International Criminal Court.
Will he be sent over to The Hague?
The idea of justice needs to be set to the
maximum satisfaction of the victim, is something
that was a well-articulated in the constitutional
transitional period document.
We will definitely uphold that.
There are four ways of addressing this.
The ICC is one of them.
ICC itself has so many levels.
It could be an ICC in Hague could be an ICC
compliant court that is in Sudan or in the
region, transitional justice, issues of truth
and reconciliation, compensation individual
and community.
We are not going to rest until the victims,
those victims to be satisfied that justice
not only being perceived but actually being
served.
And that is how we see it.
From what I understand all options are now
open.
You still haven't decided whether it be, in
the Hague or in Sudan or in a regional court,
are all options open?
Yea of course, of course.
This is something you know, the announcement
of this was part of our peace negotiations.
And I think this is something, I want to tell
you one thing, any person who committed atrocities,
criminal, financial, will have to be tried
and that is our bottom line.
We are working on rebuilding our judiciary
system and all that.
And we hope to have a credible independent
judicial system, Sudanese.
Let's talk about Germany and your visit to
Germany, the past couple of days have been
quite historic in Sudan Germany relations.
Concretely how can Germany help Sudan in this
phase?
The meeting with the chancellor Excellency
Angela Merkel yesterday provided an opportunity
for us to reflect, discuss in depth our interest
our mutual interests for that matter and we
agreed on concrete areas that German would
work with us supporting us whether it is the
economy, the energy sector, vocational training,
mining, agriculture seminars.
And we're very delighted.
This is signalling a new beginning of this
relationship which has very high promise.
And we look forward to this cooperation that
would also allow other partners and friends
and nations to follow suit, what the German
is doing.
You mentioned the economy, Sudan badly needs
foreign investment.
What are your plans to attract foreign investment
to Sudan?
Your government's plans?
Sudan is a very rich country.
We don't want to live on hand outs, we are
so rich in a sense that if we are able to
create the right climate, meaning getting
it right in the legal sphere independent judiciary
system, respect for property rights and all
that, and we are working on this, creating
a one stop shop for investors, creating an
environment where a serious, genuine investors
come work with us pay their taxes and be able
to repatriate whatever profit they make.
And we are creating that environment and we're
very confident we'll get there.
Sudan is surrounded by many countries that
have seen change because of popular uprisings
and many of them have descended into chaos.
Is Sudan different?
Absolutely.
Sudan is different in the sense that we are
in this middle, as you mentioned it, whether
you call it the Sahel or centre of Africa.
Sudan’s change is unique in many respects.
It's peaceful.
It has great hopes for the entire region.
I call it, getting it right in Sudan has a
strategic impact and effect.
You can imagine the spill over effect in the
entire region, impact in the north, west,
south and east.
What we would like to see is our friends and
partners working with us in making this a
success story.
It has all the right ingredients of making
it as success in this sea of misery and conflict
around us.
That's why it is a unique experiment, unique
in nature and all that, and let us get friends
and partners working with us.
The world, and that particular part of the
world is looking for success stories that
were absent for a long period of time.
Sudan is giving that hope is giving that opportunity.
Let us grab it.
Let us work together on it and make it a real
success story that will change the face of
that part of the world.